okay I just got to take a second to talk
about the official Dragon Ball Twitter
account because this has been
cracking me up lately so it's been clear
for a while now that the official
English Dragon Ball Twitter account is
more or less powered on three pennies a
rotating intern and hopes and dreams if
you're watching this Mr and Mrs Twitter
intern I'm here to comfort you if you
need it but lately the account has been
on a spree of uploading their own scans
of Dragon Ball media in tandem with the
Japanese Twitter account here you see
the original Japanese post and here you
see oh dear God I don't know where the
poor intern got their scans from
presumably from a dumpster behind Big
Lots but what have they done to my boy
beerus here this ain't their first rodeo
with the mystery 1994 scanner either
they've been posting deep fried scans
for a while now and it just gets me
every single time